alex smith
cleared to return to full football
activities one of the biggest surprises
in recent months as it relates to nfl
news and a pleasant one a guy who we
thought his career was over he'd never
be back he had the compound fracture he
had the serious infection he almost died
it was a long hard road he is now
cleared to return
not just to a normal life but to play
football chris i was astounded by this
and man it instantly gets the juices
flowing on the possibility the
washington team
trying to adjust on the fly to a season
without an off season program makes me
think of 2011 alex smith with the 49ers
after the lockout no off-season program
then not much hope for the 49ers that
year oh they almost went to the super
bowl with alex smith as the quarterback
the guy has done well in the nfl over
the last decade he's still only 36 years
old
i'm fascinated by
what ron rivera may decide to do at the
quarterback position yes you've got
dwayne haskins but if alex smith is
healthy and full clearance to return to
football activities would suggest that
he is
possibility for the week one starter in
washington well it is you're right i
mean it gives them options no doubt i
mean let's not forget they traded for
kyle allen from the carolina panthers
because ron rivera had history with them
there too
so they got three like you know quality
guys and dwayne haskins is the guy still
with the greatest potential you know i
would have a hard time thinking unless
it just the the the wheels fell off and
training cam that it wouldn't be
his job to go with i mean there's things
to look at with daniel haskins game and
go oh you know he could be a star we'll
see you know what alex smith is and i
know he's cleared to play and do all
football activities but that doesn't
mean he's necessarily full go 100
alex smith the way he was before he got
injured yeah he might be able to do you
know all the drills and practice and all
that but he still might not be totally
able to hop around the pocket and run
the way to his full capabilities to me
mike
this smells like
quarantine quarterback
i uh quarantined quarterback he's the
perfect guy you know why this is the guy
i mean you're getting close we like this
your experience we know what you're
doing we're gonna keep you in quarantine
we don't think you need a ton of ton of
reps we'll get you in training camp
we'll go with haskins and and and you
know kyle allen and then you got alex
smith there's an insurance policy
because he's certainly not going to get
cut by the team with what they owe him
right right now so he's gonna be there
uh but but nonetheless i'm excited for
alex smith who's a really good guy and
uh has fought hard to get back
give me that one more time yeah
quarantine quarterback
i don't know what inspires that it's
kind of like lounge singer right that's
what it was it was that's what i was
being a lounge singer right yeah all
right uh i i but i still think that in
this upside-down topsy-turvy year if he
is truly good to go
and you're right there may be a
difference between being clear for
football activities and being 100 or
being the guy that you were
but i look at it this way
right this isn't a horrible knee injury
like teddy bridgewater had this is a
broken bone
and one thing we know about broken bones
they heal
they did and this was about all the
stuff that went on around the broken
bone the infection because the bone
broke through the skin once the bone
breaks through the skin it's all of the
crap that's on your skin that gets
inside your body and sets the stage for
the horrible infection that he had and
then on top of it he's on the grass
there's dirt there's sweat there's
there's crud it it makes it almost
impossible to avoid an infection this
wasn't he had a horrible knee injury
that continues to have complications and
he's you know yeah he's cleared for
football but he can you know what maybe
he's going to favor one leg over the
other let's see but but i just think
that when when we look at all the things
you're going to need
to be successful this year and hey hey
scott turner is the offensive
coordinator it's a new offense for
dwayne haskins right not a new offense
for alex smith norv turner was alex
smith's offensive coordinator in 2006.
now it was a long time ago but
relearning is different than learning
the first time
and and if ron rivera is committed to
going with the best guy remember he
seemed kind of ambivalent about dwayne
haskins you throw in the leadership
potential the importance of having
somebody who's going to speak with
clarity to the locker room and tell all
these young guys to go home and stay
home
i i can't rule out
the possibility that alex smith wins the
job and that uh dwayne haskins becomes
quarantine quarterback
well you're right i mean it could go the
other way around certainly you know
you're going to have to keep one of you
know uh
alex smith certainly has played a lot of
football you're right him relearning
that offense and the language is going
to take nothing for the for him to get
back up to speed plus he's played so
much football you know when you get to
that point in your career you know it's
the offense it's just hey relearning
words and things like that but yeah it'd
be interesting to see what they do i
mean they legitimately have three
options at the quarterback position i
like what we saw from haskins but you're
right there's questions we don't know
and if he stumbles learning this offense
and whoa alex smith is like whoa he's
he's really running around and he's
actually is a hundred percent
yeah maybe maybe you think about it
certainly i i don't i don't put that you
know if you have the three guys though
you know i guess this is something i
haven't wrapped them around my head like
what's the guy that's the smart one you
want to put on the quarantine
quarterback right because like you also
got to think like wait we might be in a
game and
this guy gets hurt and i want to have
the better player to be the backup to
come in not necessarily you know over at
home in quarantine so
that'll be a juggling act and something
for them to figure out as well yeah with
the young guy as starter yeah haskins
do you get more support for him week in
and week out day in and day out i mean
when you quarantine a quarterback are
you just keeping away from the team at
all times if that's what you're doing
you're losing the benefit of now you can
still interact you're just never in the
same building i mean it all depends on
on how they decide to integrate that
quarterback room if you're not in the
same room but you can be involved in
virtual meetings
uh maybe alex smith is the guy who's
there on game day he's ready to go and
ready to talk and able to talk to dwayne
haskins as as needed um you know another
point chris and i think this is entirely
relevant because there's a huge
similarity between you and alex smith
two quarterbacks who had a sudden injury
nearly died
and then had a chance to come back now
for you the issue with the
proprioception the absence of the spleen
it prevented you from ever getting back
to the guy that you were right but think
about your mindset when you knew you
were gonna have a chance to come back
and play again
after almost dying
after facing the possibility that you
would never play again to finally get
back on the field oh that mindset's got
to be powerful it's got to be and if
alex smith can do it if he if he's 100
and he can do it you combine that that
fulfilled dream that you never thought
was going to come true the opportunity
to play again he could be unstoppable no
no doubt
it's like um
you know it's it is it's like one of
those things where you just you feel
like you got a second life all of a
sudden you're going man i thought it was
over it's done i'm never gonna have to
play again everything's ruined and then
you're just oh this is so awesome i'm
back i'm great i'm so grateful to be
here and you know my my approach was one
the pressure was off because i was like
well i mean yeah i mean playing a game
is pressure but like how about not being
able to throw the ball 10 yards when you
could throw it 70 yards your whole life
that that was pressure where i was every
day i was waking up like what the hell
is wrong with me dad dad i'm coming home
because i can't throw the ball 10 yards
anymore i don't know what happened i
used to have one of the strongest you
know so i was going through all of that
and then when i finally started to get
close to 100 and oh my gosh was just the
the pressure off me the love of the game
was just like you just you know flowing
through my brain everything i was so
happy to be back and then so willing to
work just like oh oh you know whatever i
got to be there for 15 hours so what
it's better than trying to figure out
how to throw again in the backyard so
you're right he's going to be very
powerful that way and it'll be
interesting i don't think you put dwayne
haskins in quarantine quarterback that's
the one thing i know he's a rookie he
needs to be there he needs the reps all
those type of things uh but i'm very
happy for alex smith and and hopefully
he can make this interesting and make
washington think about what the hell
they got to do here at this situation
so if alex smith is 100
where would he land
on the chris sims quarterback top 40 oh
you know that's a good question i i
think you know realistically right now
you know coming off the injury he's not
going to be in that top 20 group for me
there so if you could switch to the next
page there i think like if i had to and
i knew he was i think he's like right
around maybe that
you know
right below case keenum maybe somewhere
in there if i knew he was totally for a
hundred percent healthy you know case
keenum jameis winston ty rod taylor alex
smith i think they're all in that same
group along with nick foles i think that
would probably be fair that's where i'd
have him at least right now you know
when he was healthy and before the
injury he was dancing around the top 20
a number of times
well that's higher than dwayne haskins
who's number 39 so rock paper scissors
alex smith is the starter for the
washington football team in 2020 if he's
100 and i don't know what's i don't know
what's going to happen right but it's
just a fascinating story and it's a
good positive uplifting message to see a
guy come back from so much adversity and
get back to the nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports